how do you avoid or do you avoid getting
totally black pilled and saying oh well
the lips have all the power all hope is
lost I might as well sit on my couch and
eat potato chips full of ceilings it's
not really yeah yeah and those heroes
are really good if you want to get
estrogen and grow breasts but my point
being uh this is this is what I'm saying
is it's impossible not to give black
filled too when you realize guys like
damn Crenshaw that say their
conservatives are giving you know
billions of dollars in the Ukraine so
for me I mean you know how do we fight
that that sense of like oh you know
black belt like how do we
um you know get out of that mindset it's
difficult for me but at the same time
that's the harsh reality in which we
live in the government I don't think has
our best interest and it's just kind of
living positive and creating some sort
of future that you like because what
happens is they trick us into playing
their reindeer games you know they trick
you into wearing the mask they trick you
into getting vaccinated with the free
hamburger you know and if you don't fall
for their tricks then you can live a
happy life so getting black filled it's
impo it's impossible not to have that
feeling sometimes but there's a lot of
Hope and joy with being awake to
realizing breaking out of that cognitive
dissonance knowing that the government
you might think they have your best
interests but really they don't so you
mentioned Crenshaw and you know know I I
saw your video on Crenshaw and I thought
that was one of the examples where I
thought isn't this a little too far you
know yeah is Crenshaw more moderate than
I don't know then us and probably a lot
of the listeners yes but you know I like
the guy personally and I just thought is
that is that an example where you think
you know it's it's a little too impolite
the guy's a wounded veteran you know
even if I don't like his politics or do
you think no screw him I don't like him
and you know I'll say whatever
and I don't want to be insensitive to
Veterans I respect every single man and
woman in a military uniform but at the
end of the day the whole entire military
the military-industrial complex and the
imperialistic mindset that the you know
American Military has is disgusting I
mean I think about the millions of
people that died in the Middle East I
mean on World War II I think was the
last justifiable war that we've had so
when I look at people like Dan Crenshaw
and the other veterans that I talked to
that have been injured they become
staunchly anti-war I'm a conflict
interventionalist I will never say that
war is good and I know that's not
necessarily a conservative viewpoint but
I I don't think as human beings right
now we're fighting a proxy war against
Russia and Ukraine over the Don bass
region and for them not wanting to go
into NATO that's all we have to do is
just say they won't join NATO and keep
the dawn bass region autonomous where
they can choose whatever country they
want to go to and we're saying no
because we are benefiting from a proxy
war because people that it's not people
that run the country it is multinational
corporations like Halliburton like
Pfizer that can buy and sell these
politicians on both sides like toilet
paper through their political action
committee Dan Crenshaw is a guy that
kicked out service members from being in
the military through the National
Defense authorization act that weren't
vaccinated kicked out service members in
the Army Reserve that weren't vaccinated
so if he really cared about Americans he
would actually you know care about these
military guys that don't want to take a
vaccine that was tested on eight mice my
point being it doesn't matter because
these corporations are running and
calling the shots we're not being ran by
humans you think freaking Halliburton
could be empathetic when they drop a
drone strike on a wedding when we left
Afghanistan Joe Biden killed four
children nobody says a word about it so
you know it's just if these were human
beings running the country then they
would be more empathetic to other human
beings but at the end of the day because
these are CEOs we live in a
corporatocracy and not a real country
anymore sadly no you know I I don't
dispute a lot of that I I guess the
question I'm asking tactically is you
know if
in order to make that point are you
saying that the situation is just so
dire and the kind of the Public
Communication is so staged that it is
necessary to say and do things that are
impolite or rude or you know or immoral
even I mean because that's I just think
when I think about the Crenshaw thing I
think and you know given I I do like the
guy at a personal level but obviously we
have very different views on Ukraine he
and I and probably on a lot of other
issues too or I think about even AOC who
I don't like at a personal level and I
think you know it's one of your most
popular videos and it's one of those
things where you think this isn't this
is rude this isn't right I shouldn't but
you're kind of like giggling off in the
corner because it's kind of funny and
but you think you know
I don't know I couldn't bring myself to
say to say to a woman like hey you've
got a big booty and you're my favorite
well that's why I'm saying Michael and
listen this is the other problem is
because if you look at the top movies
from the 90s it's like Shawshank
Redemption American Pie uh Pulp Fiction
if you look at the top movies of 2021 it
is literally uh other than Top Gun the
highest grossing movie was Sonic the
Hedgehog 2. so we need some political
incorrectness we need somebody saying
you got a big booty and I know that
that's no not the nicest thing and
probably not the you know uh you know
it's a little Unbecoming of a gentleman
at the same time it is harmless I am
complimenting her she is ginny From the
Block I mean I know she's not Jennifer
Lopez but she's from that you don't
think she's ever been cat called by a
construction worker I get cat called in
New York city so if she I do and I'm an
imbecile then I'm sure she's been
tackled so this is the point though is
when I go after guys like Crenshaw this
is his problem is that the NPCs are
talking about he gets so his ego is so
big and same with AOC is that they have
to react now when I made fun of Eric
swallow and I said oh did you and bang
bang you know did you guys you know and
you know what kind of sex did you have
with bang bang or you know did you sleep
with bang bang he was smart he's dead
silent kept his head down Adam kinzinger
same thing I made fun of him for dinner
but these these other politicians that
let me play with them in the video game
of life that's their they shouldn't get
in the in the mud with a pig like me
Michael that's their problem so it's
just Dan Kershaw if he didn't play ball
so much then I wouldn't have to make him
personally you know and Public Enemy
Number One so it's just they if they
were a little more down to earth that
that's the other problem though Michael
is that we have a Down to Earth problem
is these politicians as soon as they get
elected they have this era of authority
where they think they're better than
everybody and that's not the case
everybody has issues everybody is the
same and that's like a socialistic kind
of you know mindset but really we all
have problems we all have issues and
nobody is really necessarily better than
anybody else well that that is the best
explanation I've heard of this is
basically you're you're basic you're
going out there
to just see who will take the bait and I
think you're right about small well I
mean I think you're right the fact that
swalwell just
just kept on moving he said there's no
win here I'm obviously the moment I
react I'm gonna lose and he kept going
it's probably smart and some of the
other guys I mean I think you did one to
Jerry Nadler is that right
no that was a Pluckers I think Jared
nather that's okay yeah yeah but but I
mean listen and I've yelled and I've you
know a beta O'Rourke and you're getting
their politician's face and it's better
for them not like I just have to use
that quote you know you don't want to
get in the mud with a pig like me but
this is other things we need to humanize
these politicians and we do need to call
them out now you saw these guys that are
actually liberal guys that called out
AOC for being a Warhawk and that gets 10
million views because people want to see
these politicians humanize and so that's
what I try to do is it's not even that
I'm really trying to be necessarily mean
if you notice a lot of my content I try
to make myself the butt of the joke
because I don't even really want to be
me and I'm trying to make fun of Myself
by Asher turfing as these crazy people
or you know like the whatever the status
quo of the left like saying you know my
wife's boyfriend dontarius
yeah I bring up I have a lot of little
things uh that I can just use that is
basically uh become a symbol of the left
and that's the thing is we've all become
caricatures of ourselves there's people
in the far right that are annoying
there's people on the far left that are
but for all these people that talk about
Q Anon it'll never talk about the blue
Anon for 2016 where they said the
election was stolen so it's calling out
hypocrisy is my point Michael and that's
what I want to do is just try to call
out the people especially the mainstream
media that's hypocritical and the
politicians I've yet to meet very few
Marjorie Taylor green that have become
friends with she's not very hypocritical
uh and you know Thomas Massey that I've
interacted with a few of the ones that
I've interacted with that have been nice
even Madison cawthorne wasn't very
hypocritical I feel like I've dealt with
a lot of people that very few of them
are actually good the majority of them
are
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]